[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland dem täglichen truecrime
Podcast von Bild mein Name ist Mirko
Kasimir und ich bin Natalie Strauß und
bevor es losgeht ist mal wieder eine
triggerwarnung angebracht heute geht es
um ein wahnsinnig brutales Verbrechen in
Frankreich der 30er Jahre das damals das
ganze Land erschüttert hat und bis heute
fassungslos macht aber wir fangen
harmlos an Mirko Aschenputtel kennst du
oder das Märchen ja klar logisch mein
Gefühl tausend Fassung von den Gebrüdern
Grimm dann diesen DEFA Kultfilm drei
Haselnüsse für Aschenbrödel Disneys
Cinderella sehr gut sehr gut aber heute
geht es um eine etwas andere Version
okay bin gespannt also pass auf
böse Stiefmutter etc klassisches Märchen
Setup sie muss schuf und schuften
während sich die Stiefmutter und deren
Töchter richtig gut gehen lassen und
wann immer es geht auf Partys abhängen
na ich denke das wissen alle oder aber
eines Tages schleicht sich Aschenputtel
auf das Fest des Königssohnes und nee
nee nee die Fassung meine ich nicht
eines Tages schnappt sie sich einen
Hammer er schlägt die Stiefmutter und
durch die Schwestern und schneidet ihn
in die Augen aus dem Kopf
Natalie ich glaube das ist definitiv
nicht die Disney Version nein das ist
die True Crime Version mit den beiden
Schwestern Lea und Kristin Papa in der
Rolle von Aschenputtel leider muss diese
Fassung ohne verzauberte Kutsche
hilfreiche Tauben Happy End und wenn sie
nicht gestorben sind auskommen und ganz
besonders ohne Märchenprinz aber
ansonsten ich meine so viel bleibt da
jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr übrig hä aber
du hast Recht die Grundsituation Arme
dienstmärkte miese Arbeitgeber ja das
gibt's in Märchen naja und leider nicht
nur im Märchen sondern auch im wahren
Leben und in der heutigen Zeit dafür
aber gibt es eindeutig viel zu wenig
Märchenprinzen das muss dieser
Fachkräftemangel sein von dem Fotografie
hört aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
die Geschwister Papa wirklich so auf
einen Märchenprinzen abgefahren wären
ja ich glaube es wird Zeit dass wir an
dieser Stelle einfach mal mit der echten
Geschichte loslegen Mirko na klar am
besten fange ich mit den papa-schwestern
an Kristin Papa wird am 8 märz 1905 Lea
Papa am 15 september 1911 geboren kennen
viele wahrscheinlich vor allem durch das
berühmte Autorennen das seit 1923 dort
ausgetragen wird in lehrper-haus
Geburtsjahr 1911 findet erstmals ein
Grand Prix in Lemon statt die beiden
haben keine glückliche Kindheit ihre
Eltern sind Clemence und Gustav Papa
die Mutter ist weder fürsorglich noch
liebevoll der Vater ist brutal und
verfällt im Alkohol schon kurz nach der
Geburt geben Sie die Mädchen Weg
Christin kommt zu einer Tante
väterlicherseits leer zu einem Onkel
mütterlicherseits und vielleicht ist das
auch tatsächlich das beste was die
Eltern je für die beiden tun zumindest
von Christine ist bekannt dass die
sieben Jahre die sie bei der Tante
verbringt eine relativ glückliche Zeit
sind Kristin und Lea haben noch eine
ältere Schwester Emilia geboren 1902 und
sie bleibt bei ihren Eltern leider muss
man sagen denn 1912 wird der Vater
beschuldigt die zehn Jahre alte Emilia
vergewaltigt zu haben und es wird noch
übler Clemens die Mutter bezieht sich
Ihr Kind den Vater verführt zu haben und
ich sag's mal so wer so eine Mutter hat
braucht keine bösen Märchen Stiefmutter
mehr sie schickt ihre Tochter Nachbar
ein katholisches Weisenhaus das als
besonders anstrenggeld bald darauf
kommen auch Christin und Lea nach
Bompastor kurz noch zu Emilia sie wird
nie wieder zu ihrer Familie oder in ein
bürgerliches Leben zurückkehren sondern
tritt später in ein Kloster ein wird
Norne und verbringt so den Rest ihres
Lebens naja das ist aber auch irgendwie
verständlich und es ist vielleicht auch
kein Wunder dass Christin sich ebenfalls
entschließt Nonne zu werden was die
Mutter aber verbietet mit 15 soll sie
wieder zurück nach Hause kommen um zu
arbeiten wenigstens ist der Vater dort
nicht mehr denn die Eltern haben sich
inzwischen scheiden lassen Kristin
beginnt als dienstmarkt zu arbeiten
zuerst allein doch als Lehrer alt genug
ist und ebenfalls arbeiten kann oder
besser gesagt muss versuchen die beiden
Schwestern wann immer es möglich ist
gemeinsam angestellt zu werden und man
ist doch sehr zufrieden mit ihnen
Christin ist zwar manchmal sehr
aufmüpfig aber sie ist fleißig und eine
äußerst gute Küche die jüngere Lehrer
hingegen gilt als sehr ruhig
introvertiert sind sehr gehorsam aber
trotzdem bleiben sie anfangs nie lange
in einem Haushalt denn ihre Mutter ist
oft mit der Bezahlung unzufrieden und
schickt sie weiter zur nächsten Familie
wenn dort mir Geld zu verdienen ist okay
das klingt jetzt aber erstmal gar nicht
so schlecht sie will halt das Beste für
ihre Kinder rausholen ja aber leider ist
das nicht unbedingt die Motivation denn
das Geld zahlen die Arbeitgeber
größtenteils an Sie Lea und Kristin
erhalten nur ein klitzeklein Anteil es
geht Dir also vor allem um sich selbst
ganz tolle Mutter wie gesagt
1926 wird Christin bei der Familie Lars
long angestellt die Lars longs wohnen in
einem schicken zwei stückigen Haus in
der rubriär 6 in lemont René Larsson ein
wohlhabender Rechtsanwalt im Ruhestand
hat es für sich seine Frau Leonie
larsler und ihre Tochter gekauft
eine ältere Schwester Genie Vers ist
bereits verheiratet und außer Haus
Christin bezieht als Zimmermädchen eine
Kammer im Obergeschoss und nach einigen
Monaten guter Arbeit kann sie Madame
Lars überzeugen auch ihre Schwester Lea
einzustellen fortan leben sie gemeinsam
in der kleinen Kammer und kümmern sich
um den Haushalt der Lars ja das ist ein
bisschen anders als heutzutage mit
Putzfrau oder Babysitter damals sind
dienstmärkte Teil des Haushalts und ich
sag hier ganz bewusst nicht der Familie
also ihr so wie ein Au-Pair heute
vielleicht
nee das trifft es auch nicht Au Pairs
wohnen bei Gastfamilien und das Wort
zeigt ja schon dass das was anderes ist
als eine reine dienstbeziehung zumindest
solltest das sein Au-pairs wollen das
Land die Leute die Kultur kennenlernen
und sich nicht irgendwie den Buckel
krumm schuften und dann noch den
größtenteils des mikrigen Gehalts an die
Mutter abzugeben ja das stimmt natürlich
da hast du recht es gab natürlich auch
eine ganz klare Grenze da waren
einerseits die Herren bzw Damen und
andererseits die Dienerinnen und von
Augenhöhe oder Respekt gegenüber den
Mädchen konnte da absolut keine Rede
sein ja vielleicht sollten wir uns auf
das Verhältnis zwischen den
papa-schwestern und den longs longs
einmal ansehen die beiden wurden nicht
schlecht bezahlt also für diesen Job und
die damaligen Verhältnisse ja logisch
sonst hätte ihre Mutter sich auch bald
wieder woanders hingeschickt ja ganz
sicher die longs sind jedenfalls für
ihre Zeit faire Arbeitgeber z.B bekommen
die beiden Schwestern dasselbe essen wie
die Familie was sowohl gar keine
Selbstverständlichkeit ist und noch
etwas passiert Kristin kann Madame Lars
Lounge schließlich überzeugen das Geld
nicht mehr an die Mutter sondern
komplett an sie auszuzahlen und das muss
für die beiden Schwestern eine
riesengroße Befreiung gewesen sein
jetzt bleibt also genug für sich selbst
übrig für Kleider fürs Kino für was auch
immer junge Frauen damals mit Geld
anstellen können oder wollen ja aber da
ist nicht viel dass sie wollen es wird
berichtet dass sie weder ins Kino gehen
noch an anderen vergnungen interessiert
sind stattdessen sind sie immer zu zweit
meist in ihrer Kammer bis auf Sonntag da
ziehen sie sich ihre besten Sachen an
und gehen in die Kirche sie haben keine
Freunde und es gibt auch keine Männer in
ihrem Leben sie sind sich offenbar
selbst genug das muss so eine
unglaublich enge Beziehung gewesen sein
zwischen den beiden ja und das hat
später ja auch zu den Gerüchten über
eine inzesturiöse Liebe zwischen den
beiden geführt aber du wolltest doch
etwas über das Verhältnis der beiden zur
Familie erzählen genau die ist nämlich
äußerst seltsam das grasste ist schon
mal dass der Mann René longs long in den
insgesamt sieben Jahren die die beiden
in dem Haus sind nie mit ihm spricht das
ist schon wirklich wirklich sehr irre
oder ja oder und die Frau die
kommuniziert größtenteils über Zettel
mit ihnen da steht dann drauf was sie zu
tun haben und das war es auch schon am
Kommunikation außer wenn etwas schief
geht oder die Hausherrin meint dass
etwas schief gegangen ist also ein
herzliches Verhältnis ist das definitiv
nicht definitiv nicht wissen wir denn
eigentlich woran das liegt boah du
merkst keine Ahnung manche sagen es sei
die Arroganz und die Herzlosigkeit der
herrschenden Klasse die sich da einfach
manifestiert aber vielleicht sind es
einfach bloß keine besonders netten
Menschen vielleicht sind die Schwestern
auch so seltsam und in sich gekehrt dass
die Hausherren den Kontakt lieber auf
das Nötigste beschränkt jedenfalls wird
mit den Jahren alles noch schlimmer
Leonie erkrankt an einer Depression und
sie wird unausstehlich sie zieht leer
und Christin bei jeder Gelegenheit und
gewöhnt sich an mit weißen Handschuhen
über die Oberflächen des Hauses zu
fahren und wer es findet sich irgendwo
Kopf dann werden die beiden rund gemacht
und es kommt wohl sogar zu körperlichen
Angriffen einmal soll sie die Köpfe der
jungen Frauen gegen die Wand geschlagen
haben hallo und damit kommen wir zum
zweiten februar 1933
vertreiben sich den regnerischen Tag mit
einkaufsbummeln in Le Mans später am
Abend wollen sie eine Feier im Haus von
Leonies Bruder besuchen und dort wohl
auch die Nacht verbringen die
papa-schwestern sind unterdessen mit
Hausarbeiten und Besorgungen beschäftigt
am Abend holen Sie ein Bügeleisen ab
dass sie zur Reparatur in eine Werkstatt
gebracht haben als sie das Bügeleisen
jedoch anschließen wollen gibt es einen
Kurzschluss und den ganzen Haus gehen
die Lichter aus
da sie nicht mit der Rückkehr der
Hausherren rechnen beschließen sie das
Problem auf den nächsten Morgen zu
vertagen aber Leonie und Jennifer kommt
zurück während der Fahrerin die noch
unterwegs ist und Leonie rastet aus die
Schwestern versuchen noch zu erklären
was geschehen ist doch Leonie Lars
glaubt ihn überhaupt nicht und gibt
ihnen die Schuld und attackiert Kristin
auf dem Treppenabsatz im ersten Stock
und in diesem Moment muss in Christin
etwas zerbrochen oder aufgebrochen sein
eine Wut die sich über Jahre angestaut
hat
Kristin greift einen zinkkrug und
schlägt in der Hausherrin auf den Kopf
deren Tochter genevierf schreit auf und
stürzt sich auf Christin während die
beiden Kämpfen kommt Lea die Treppe
heruntergerannt um ihrer Schwester zu
helfen und greift Leonie an Kristin
schreit schmetter ihren Kopf auf den
Boden und reiße die Augen aus und Lea
tut was ihre ältere Schwester ihr
befiehlt Gottes wenn sie reißt Leonie
los die Augen raus mit den Fingern
Jennifer leidet dasselbe Kristin
ergreift ihre Augen und
oh ist das Übel
also sie reißen wirklich beiden die
Augen heraus komplett ich ich will mir
das einfach gar nicht vorstellen das
Blut Gesichter ohne Augen die Schreie
denn die beiden leben noch die
Schwestern holen einen Hammer und ein
Messer und schlagen auf ihre Opfer ein
bis sie verstummt sind dann verstümen
sie die ohnehin schon grauenhaft
zugerichteten Leichen weiter mit dem
Messer
[Musik]
als René nach Hause kommt um seine Frau
und seine Tochter für die Feier
abzuholen steht da vor einem
verschlossenen dunklen Haus oben im
Zimmer der Dienstmädchen scheintlich zu
brennen aber niemand öffnet longs love
vermutet dass die beiden schon bei
Leonies Bruder sind doch als er sie dort
ebenfalls nicht antrifft verständigt er
die Polizei die ihn dann in die rubruar
begleitet und die Tür aufbricht sie
stoßen sofort auf die Leichen finden
auch die herausgerissenen Augen und
das klingt wirklich abgedroschen aber
was René Lars law in diesem Moment
gefühlt haben muss das kann sich wohl
kaum jemand ausmalen aber es muss die
Hölle gewesen sein doch wo sind die
beiden Schwestern sind sie ebenfalls
Opfer des Monsters geworden was sie
gewütet hat die Tür zu ihrer Kammer ist
abgeschlossen auf mehrfaches klopfen
kommt keine Antwort die Polizisten rufen
eine Schlosser der die Tür schließlich
öffnen soll Christin und Lea Papa liegen
nackt auf dem Bett sie halten einander
in Armen und schauen den Polizisten die
jetzt hereinstimmen ruhig entgegen auf
einem Stuhl liegt ein Hammer Blut
verschmiert an dem noch die Haare ihre
Opfer kleben
[Musik]
sie lassen sich umstandslos festnehmen
und gestehen die Morde sofort Christin
sagt es war entweder sie oder wir Lea
sagt ich bin ab jetzt taubstumm die
Tatort der Prozess sind eine Sensation
Frankreich ist schockiert und wohl auch
fasziniert von der Grausamkeit der Morde
und nicht zuletzt wohl auch von dem
Detail dass die beiden nackt und eng
umschlungen im Bett aufgefunden wurden
aber es gibt auch viele die die
Schwestern verteidigen die den Mord als
eine Auflehnung gegen ein unmenschliches
Klassensystem ansehen aber die beiden
sind keine RevolutionärInnen sie sind
gequälte Seelen und krank obwohl erste
Gutachter zu dem Schluss kommen dass sie
nicht an einer psychischen Störung
leiden stellt sich später heraus dass es
in ihrer Familie eine Vorgeschichte von
Geisteskrankheiten gibt man
diagnostiziert schließlich eine Foyer
einen Wahnsinn zu zweit oder das ist die
wissenschaftliche Bezeichnung eine
induzierte wahnhafte Störung die zum
Beispiel auftreten kann wenn zwei
Menschen von der Welt isoliert sind
einer von ihnen eine Paranoia entwickelt
und den anderen dominiert und ihn
sozusagen mit dieser Paranoia ansteckt
hier ist natürlich die ältere Christine
diese dominierte Person und die
sanftmütige Lea folgt ihr in die
Krankheit
trotz dieser Diagnose wird Kristin zum
Tod durch die guillotin verurteilt das
Urteil wird allerdings später an eine
lebenslange Haft umgewandelt Lea sieht
man als Opfer ihrer Schwester an und
verurteilt sie zu zehn Jahren Haft aber
die wahre Strafe für die beiden ganz
besonders für Christin ist dass die
beiden getrennt werden und sich niemals
wiedersehen sie fällt in eine tiefe
Depression hat Anfälle von Wahnsinn
einmal versucht sie sogar sich selbst
die Augen raus zu reißen unverweigert
schließlich das Essen
sie wird vom Gefängnis in eine
psychiatrische Anstalt verlegt das hätte
man von Anfang an tun sollen doch ist es
zu spät im Mai 1937 stirbt Kristin Papa
an Abmagerung ihre Schwester wird nach
acht Jahren wegen guter Führung aus der
Haft entlassen und lebt fortan unter
einem neuen Namen in Nord zusammen mit
und das ist eine ziemliche Überraschung
ihrer Mutter ihr Geld verdient sie als
Zimmermädchen in Hotels
1966 kann ein Journalist sie aufspüren
im Gespräch mit ihm sagt sie über ihre
Schwester Christin beobachtet mich sie
ist immer schön und jung und sie lächelt
wie in alten Zeiten mit Ironie
ich zerfalle ich schrumpfe ich schwitze
vor Angst ich falle in Ohnmacht
die Geschichte der Papa Schwester und
der Familie Lars long haben wir unter
anderem anhand von Beiträgen auf history
101.com
sowie der französischen und englischen
Wikipedia erzählt vielen Dank dass ihr
dabei wart und wenn es euch gefallen hat
empfehlt uns gern weiter und Bewertet
uns wo immer ihr diesen Podcast hört und
vor allem seid bald wieder bei uns bis
dahin eure Natalie und euer Mirko